legends of an ancient race of giants are
shared among cultures that span across
multiple continents from around the
world and are included in the most
common religions here on earth as well
including Christianity Judaism Islam
Hinduism and even Buddhism to name a few
examples in fact even the Sumerians who
are the earliest documented human
civilization on record also share
details of a race of giants once living
here on earth even the ancient Greeks
described the Giants included among the
Greek gods and there are many different
words that have been used to describe
the race of massive humans such as the
Nephilim from the Bible the food people
in the Koran the day itas and Hinduism
and the Asura in Buddhism and
descriptions of red-haired white skin
Giants are shared by several different
Native American tribes in North America
and even reaching as far away as the
Manta people in Peru in South America
now on this channel I have made many
videos discussing massive megalithic
structures found throughout the world
many of which are just as mysterious as
they are massive as there is a huge
missing chapter within our ancient
history and that we do not know exactly
how or by who many of these structures
were created and I have received
literally thousands of comments from
people on various videos stating that
these structures were built by giants
now let me first say that I have always
assumed that the various myths and
legends of a race of giants existing on
Earth were simply exaggerated stories
passed down over thousands of years and
I figured that well if Giants actually
did exist we certainly would have found
some skeletons and remains by now and we
haven't or have we I'll be discussing
that later in this video
first let's acknowledge that there are
indeed rare examples of people growing
to be what many would consider to be a
giant perhaps the most famous example is
Andre the Giant who was seven foot four
inches tall or 224 centimeters and
weighed 520 pounds or 236 kilograms
look at just how big he is compared to
Muhammad Ali who was nearly six foot
four and look at how big his fist is
compared to Ali's head
even compare his hand to a standard 12
ounce beer can
isn't that just incredible it seems to
me that the word giant is a very
appropriate word to describe him but it
must be mentioned that he had a disorder
of excessive growth hormone which
allowed him to grow so large and
resulted in him dying of a heart attack
at 47 years of age he grew too large for
his heart to sustain him and ultimately
passing away due to complications of
what's called gigantism
in fact the tallest human to ever have
existed at least verified through
irrefutable evidence is a man named
Robert Wadlow who reached the height of
eight feet 11 inches or 272 centimeters
and he was still growing up until he
died at the early age of 22 he just like
Andre the Giant also suffered from
gigantism which is caused by hyperplasia
of the pituitary gland causing his
abnormal and excessive growth which also
caused issues in his bones and joints in
fact he needed braces for his legs just
to walk and he ended up dying actually
of an ankle infection in 1940 but
neither of these examples are the
results of being from a race of giants I
mean they weren't so large because their
parents were giants they gave birth to
other giants so is it possible that the
various myths and legends of giants
existing in the past are actually just
similar examples to modern times were in
certain rare examples people grow to be
exceptionally large that's considered
the biblical story of David versus
Goliath which is also included in the
Quran by the way with different names
Goliath being jalloo if I pronounced
that correctly but according to the King
James version of the Bible Goliath
heights when converted to modern
measurements would be nearly 10 feet
tall could this be an exaggerated figure
for someone who is actually say between
7 or 8 feet tall I speculate simply
because I'm always reminded of the
telephone game which of course is a
great way of portraying how information
always changes when it's passed down
through people over time and through
different languages I mean think about
it if you pick out a current news story
and then decide to go research that
story from three different news outlets
you're going to get three different
versions of the story every time which
is pretty odd considering is
2018 and all of our technological
abilities and abilities to well
communicate information and we still
can't get things right so just compare
the large discrepancy between the King
James description of Goliath being 9
feet 9 inches tall to the Book of Enoch
found within the Dead Sea Scrolls which
states that Goliath was actually 6 feet
7 inches
hmm that is a large discrepancy and I'll
be discussing more about the Dead Sea
Scrolls in just a moment but first it's
worth mentioning that the 6 cubits and a
span or the 9 foot 9 inch measurement
comes specifically out of the King James
version of the Bible from the year 1611
just one small example of King James
altering the Bible which is of course a
very controversial subject just like the
many allegations that the Vatican had
altered the Bible as well but that's a
topic for another video so the story of
Goliath aside let's discuss the
description of King Gilgamesh of the
ancient sumerians who is said to have
reigned in power for 126 years according
to the Sumerian king list he is said to
have been 11 cubits tall which is
equivalent to 18 feet or 5 meters it is
even detailed that his punt poles used
for moving and steering his boat were 60
cubits long each which is equivalent to
90 feet or 27 and a half meters look at
these statues of King Gilgamesh holding
a lion and this has been depicted in
many different statues so is this a baby
lion or is he a freaking giant the lion
appears to be male based on having its
Mane which would also make it in adult
many people are not aware of just how
big Lions get in fact male African lions
can exceed 500 pounds or 225 kilograms
and here are a few pictures for simple
comparison but it's really not until
you're up close to one that you realize
just how massive they are I mean their
backs are almost up to your chest and
not to mention just how long their
bodies are now obviously these statues
do not mean that Gilgamesh was actually
a giant and you could easily infer that
he raised lions and this is symbolic of
him training them or taming them or
controlling them who knows but similar
depictions are also shown in Sumerian
clay tablets as well and like I
mentioned earlier
the Sumerian tablets and statues are
from the earliest recorded human
civilization the earliest literature in
the known existence of mankind details
the existence of a race of giants and by
the way if you've seen my other videos I
do discuss other civilizations which
date back tens of thousands of years
earlier
I'm simply referring to documented
civilization in this video but some of
these tablets show individuals that are
much larger than others and this is
something that has also been depicted in
Egyptian hieroglyphs as well however
this has often been believed to be
symbolism of differentiating people of
power or royalty to everyone else so
like I mentioned a few moments ago about
the Dead Sea Scrolls it is really
interesting to mention that a race of
giants or the Nephilim who were
discussed in the Book of Enoch which was
included within the Dead Sea Scrolls
I've mentioned these Scrolls in other
videos when mentioning the book of
Watchers but if you're not familiar
these scrolls were hidden inside caves
located on the side of remote desert
cliffs near the Dead Sea and they were
buried inside of seal jars for thousands
of years it really makes you wonder why
someone or a group of people went to
such an incredible extent to hide and
preserve the information included in
these Scrolls but that's be real the
fact that Giants are written about on
some Scrolls thousands of years ago is
not evidence that a race of giants
actually existed and nor are the massive
examples of megalithic structures from
ancient times for example in my Petra
video I received hundreds of comments
suggesting that the doors are so big
because it was created and inhabited by
giants look at the so called monastery
located at Petra this building is 150
feet tall or 46 meters and I'm not
exactly sure how tall the door is but
just compare it to people now look at
this photo and in the top right corner
that is a man standing between those two
circles so why did they choose to make
the structure so big in which by the way
it was carved out of the side of a
mountain in the remote desert of Jordan
however when you look at the so-called
treasury which is also located at Petra
you can see that despite the massive
doorway the steps are of normal size and
another great example is at Baalbek in
I received many comments from people
suggesting that this site was created by
Giants and look at the size of the
unbelievably large foundation stones at
the Heliopolis and compare them to
people standing nearby and when you
ascend into the Heliopolis look at the
size of people compared to the temple of
bacchus simply massive well now look at
the door obviously that's amazing but
when you actually look at the steps you
climb to reach it you'll notice that
they are of normal size and it's the
same when you enter inside the temple as
well and you can see there on the altar
that the steps are well I would say
standard size if this was indeed for
Giants why are the steps so small in
comparison and of course when you look
at the steps that you climb up to at the
temple of Jupiter which is located right
next to the temple of bacchus I mean if
these were made for Giants again why are
the steps so small and obviously of an
appropriate size for humans now of
course that does not mean that Giants
didn't build these sites for
regular-sized people but this of course
brings us to the big question which is
that if a race of giants did exist then
where's all the evidence where's all the
skeletal remains because it seems like
we don't have bones but we have a lot of
tales and myths about it I mean you find
so many dinosaur fossils yet we haven't
found any of human giants that would
have been around far more recently in
time and this is where we get to the
conspiracy side of things where people
suggest that no wait a second we have
actually found many different skeletal
remains of giants but the evidence has
been covered up and destroyed this stems
from many different news articles that
were published in newspapers many years
ago take for example one that was
published in The New York Times from
back in 1897 which described the
discovery of a human being over nine
feet tall from head to foot and the
skull was described as being half a
bushel which correct me if I'm wrong
would be something equivalent to around
four gallons in size the article goes on
to describe that the skeleton was found
along with other relics within a mound
in Wisconsin so one topic that I have
not made a video on are the ancient
mounds of North America which many
people do not even know exists and I
need to do more research on this topic
before I make a video on it but
these mounds are scattered among many
different states in North America
including Ohio Mississippi West Virginia
Tennessee Louisiana Oklahoma Georgia
Illinois and a few other states and many
people claim that these mounds are
actually burial sites of giants and the
skeletons were removed in a cover-up
during excavations that were conducted
well over a hundred years ago there was
actually another article in The New York
Times published in 1902 reporting on an
expedition of archaeologists that had
discovered a giant skeleton in New
Mexico stating that it was 12 feet tall
which by the way that's about 366
centimeters and had a forearm that was
four feet in length and a well-preserved
lower jaw and teeth yet this teeth as
large as the size of large walnuts not
only that but the chest was said to have
a circumference of seven feet are 214
centimeters and this story was never
heard of again
did anyone actually discover a 20-foot
skeleton I really can't find an answer
about that at all but you would assume
that it's not true and these are just
two articles if you do a google search
for newspaper discoveries on Giants
you'll find quite a few articles that
date back more than a hundred years all
of discussing the discovery of Giants
even groups of two hundred giant
skeletons found in a cave all of which
exceeded nine feet tall and here are a
few examples of various newspaper
articles from long ago discussing
similar finds but there seems to be no
way to verify if any of these
discoveries were actually true and the
stories date back so long ago that
nobody involved is alive today but many
people believe that due to the
Smithsonian's involvement in many of
these excavations particularly at the
ancient mounds that the evidence was
suppressed from the masses due to
various reasons of including of course
religious implications and different
rumors and theories have been developed
over the years even stating that the
Supreme Court of the United States had
ordered the Smithsonian to disclose
their evidence but according to Snopes
which I do not consider an authority on
information any more than I do Wikipedia
which by the way I only show Wikipedia
screenshots on my videos to show the
viewer in a simple easy way that the
topic that I'm discussing is actually
documented that said Snopes declared the
to be a false story and that the Supreme
Court did not order the Smithsonian to
do anything but even if it were true
that a race of giants had been
discovered and that there was a cover-up
where the bones have been destroyed we
still should have found something by now
I mean random people have found dinosaur
bones and the remains of wooly mammoths
whether it be construction crews gold
miners people hiking on the beach or in
the woods random people have found these
remains yet we don't have people finding
the remains of massive humans I also
believe that if giant fossils had been
legitimately found the evidence would be
out by now because somebody would surely
have taken the pay day for those bones I
mean holy crap if someone actually found
a 12 or a 15-foot tall skeleton of a
human holy crap would that be a game
changer and would make somebody really
freaking rich in the process too because
those bones would be worth millions of
dollars
so surely someone would leak that
information out by now right
what I can tell you is that there is a
lot of fake crap out there on the
internet involving the discovery of
giants many different CGI photos that
are simply not real and here are just a
few examples that have been around the
internet for years one interesting story
which comes out of Egypt involve the
supposed finger of a giant which
measures 38 centimeters or 15 inches in
length and would have belonged to a
human approximately five meters in
height or 16 and a half feet tall and
these pictures were taken back in 1988
and apparently the man that had
possession of the finger was offered
money for it which he refused and then
he vanished along with the finger
neither one of them were ever seen or
heard from again and that was back in
1988 so if it was real why didn't he
submit it for testing well that is
unless it actually was real and the guy
was I don't know murdered and the finger
taken from him thus explaining why he
and the alleged finger disappeared and
have never been heard from since but
maybe it was just a total fake to begin
with a notable example of a potential
proof of a giant involves this footprint
found in South Africa long story short
dr. Robert Schoch who I admire and trust
has examined the prints and he states
that it's most likely to be natural just
like the Snowman shape figure located
just a few feet a few feet from it
and you can read the details on dr.
shocks website but it comes down to the
incredibly high temperature in which
granite is formed at shot believes that
this is simply natural yet obviously an
unusual shape and of course could be
fake as well but this is a three billion
year old stone and it's obviously
ridiculous to assume that someone
regardless of their size would step on
to molten magma or lava and obviously
you must ask how someone could make a
snowman type shape figure to go along
with it
there have been other reasons why people
have suggested that a race of giants
existed including various large
artifacts of axes or arrowheads but
there could be so many different
explanations for this such as art or
decoration now as I did more research on
this topic for making this video it
became apparent that the information
I've discussed so far is barely
scratching the surface of all the
information out there related to giants
in some way for example there were bones
found referred to as the Giants of
Castle no which allegedly is a skeleton
that would have been 11 and 1/2 feet or
three and a half meters tall
so is this legitimate or not I mean if
the bones were real then why hasn't
there been any type of modern-day study
to confirm it do you see what I'm saying
now I may make another video in the
future on the topic of giants but I
ultimately need to see more evidence or
legitimate evidence to really buy into
it but at the same time I'm a very
open-minded person and know that we are
very ignorant to historical events in
the past history of Earth so anything is
possible
but my personal thoughts are that the
myths and legends of giants actually
referred to giants of mind that people
of incredible intelligence lived long
ago and when you find various megalithic
structures that were constructed in most
likely pre diluvian times and certain
examples more specifically before the
Younger Dryas climate catastrophe of
thirteen thousand and eleven thousand
six hundred years ago perhaps in the
several millennia following this event
as mankind made its rebound in some of
the pond various megalithic sites maybe
this is how this legend was developed I
mean after all the true history of
ancient human civilization is far older
and advanced than what we were taught in
school and over the course of 12,000
years since the climate catastrophe that
is way more than enough time to erase
all the evidence excluding that of make
thick stones ultimately it is
interesting that so many different
cultures from across multiple continents
from around the world all shared this
same legend so I look forward to reading
comments that people leave as obviously
I'm not including so many different
things in this video because there's
only so much time so leave me a comment
and share your thoughts but I'm gonna
close it up there I'm Jimmy
this is bright insight hit the like
button and subscribe and I have many
more videos to come and a whole wide
variety of topics take care everybody